okay first of all hey guys so your
characters were complete jerks for a lot
of the film but still despite that still
so lovable how how
my favorite thing in the world is to
find someone on the page who's
inherently unlikable and then make it my
challenge to figure out how to get the
audience to root for her it's it's kind
of the most fun
I I would agree I think yeah unlikable
Heroes is definitely the vibe for both
of us in different ways um I think a
huge part of the lovability of both of
them is actually each other I think the
relationship between Alice and Paul and
how like ride or die they are for each
other regardless of their deep deep
flaws is just such a lovable Dynamic
that I think a lot of people relate to
whether it's a sibling or a best friend
or whatever it might be
um someone who's just like on your team
no matter what and I just loved that
none of the conflict really came from
the two of them and that they just
remained teammates throughout all the
craziness in the movie yeah well the
film is super funny I can only imagine
like behind the scenes was a joy what
was it like with Allison Janny as well
a true dream like I feel like I learned
so much I also Allison and I had been
sort of friends on the periphery forever
and I'd been dying to work with her
because I truly think she brings
something to the screen that very few
people have she is inherently playful
whether she's being serious or funny
she's so alive and it just upped the
ante for every single scene that we had
between the two of us when she was there
it was like so much more fun yeah who
are the people you hate at the wedding
because Dustin said it was crying kids
oh that's a good one crying kids well I
I don't like here's what I think
Chris Kristen we'll we'll say this for
herself but she's she's really good at
piecing out when she knows it's her time
to go and she doesn't love like big
social situations that she'll tell you
but so I really appreciate that what I
don't like is people who stay till the
end for the sake of staying to them
because they feel like they have to but
then don't go hard and engage it's like
if you're gonna stay like be part of be
part of the party like get on the floor
make it a moment and if you don't want
to do that then head home you know what
I mean I think it's all about
self-awareness and knowing like are you
down to clown or are you not and it's
fine if you away just like don't don't
pretend I'll I also want to just shatter
this stereotype right now that like
people think that the bride and groom
need s to say goodbye to you no they
don't
say goodbye to a line of people like
they're so happy you came but like I'm
just I'm using my empathy of putting
myself in that situation of a bride in a
groom that's looking at 200 people and
having to do the same exchange like a
politician or something yeah and I'm
like no just peace out but if I had to
choose one person it's like obviously
the drunk uncle
not a fun vibe at a wedding or the
funnest one
pick your poison
okay I'm gonna ask you how much did you
appreciate your family after having to
play this character who has such a
dysfunctional family
a lot go ahead go ahead no I was just
gonna say I realized how boring my
family
like no way
it's kind of this level of drama and it
was kind of it was fun throughout the
course of the movie to watch everything
unravel and there's like
I mean during the actual wedding scene
it's like there's punches and there's
peeing and there's there's cake fights
and there's just all of these things
that I had never experienced so my
family realized they were pretty lame
Ben for you you have like an [ __ ]
boyfriend in this film but in real life
you're like in love and happy so did it
make you appreciate your real life
situation so much it was it had
definitely made me appreciate and also
know I got to come and hang out with us
at the beginning of the shoot which I
loved but yeah it definitely made me
appreciate that Noah does not try to
impose any expectations on me and allows
me to just be who I am but nevertheless
I loved being with Cara and Karen is
wonderful and so funny and so gifted and
was such a fun scene partner even though
he's kind of a dick in the movie it's
but I feel like if Karns all of Karns
improvs had been kept in the movie that
the notes from the movie would have been
like more car and more car and more car
because he is so exceptional at playing
this kind of jerky guy that he he had us
rolling I love it thank you guys it was
great talking to you thank you